the water just keeps coming residents
across northern England have been
fleeing their homes in search of
emergency shelter in some areas motor
boats and kayaks are the only means of
transport the government has deployed
soldiers to help exhausted rescue teams
as we've been working our way along the
street there's been hotels and apartment
blocks moved around 40 50 people out of
a hotel another 30 or 40 yard apartment
block some people have chosen to stay
the binnacle floors and then all the dry
so they're going to stay to see how it
goes hopefully the water will start
receding soon following weeks of rain
flood warnings remain in place for
hundreds of communities in England Wales
and Scotland many are without power the
flood barriers have made a difference
both the permanent ones and the
temporary ones but it's clear in some
cases they've been overtopped they've
been overrun and so of course we should
look again about whether there's more we
can do the government has faced stiff
criticism for not spending enough on
flood prevention the hardest hit areas
include West Yorkshire which has
suffered its worst flooding in 70 years
yeah we are always in discussion with
the government to make sure that we can
get the funding that we need for the
appropriate for flood defences and
whether the flood defences would have
stopped this happening and it's
difficult to say I think it's absolutely
unprecedented but what we need to do is
is plan to ensure that this doesn't
happen again in future authorities are
warning of more severe flooding in the
coming days as waters continue to rise
you